at everything i did man like cigarettes
have been the [ __ ] hardest but this
vape [ __ ] you know smoking on the plane
you know chill out did you smoke it on
the floor yeah [ __ ] put in my hoodie
yo
like a real [ __ ]
what was like uh was we something that
you that we was just like everything i
was doing
i didn't smoke crack and i didn't shoot
needles everything about and meth is not
really on the east coast but everything
else you was participating yeah yeah
yeah i was sniffing dope like
like like sniffing coke taking xanax
before it was probably did you sniff
heroin yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ] four four
wow yeah that's that brought me to the
bottom man i was like
i never shot no needles though like and
i never so that was my thing in my head
like i'm not shooting needles i'm good
you know what i'm saying oh heroine's
like this that's some serious [ __ ] to
get off so it's crazy bro how long were
you doing heroin
it's probably like eight years wow and i
did the whole thing
the fight club [ __ ] all that [ __ ] was
was [ __ ] up so you were yo listen i
would go i remember i went on a specific
trip to detroit to battle with proof and
all of that i don't remember anything
that happened on the trip i don't i
don't if it wasn't recorded i wouldn't
even know i went there wow when i first
met alchemist i was like yo al nice to
meet you he was like
i've been [ __ ] with you since we met
in detroit i was like damn i don't even
remember that wow i don't remember
meeting one of my favorite producers
razz cass same thing he was out there
detroit judging the battle and he was
like yo i mentioned [ __ ] detroit like
well i don't i don't even remember i
wasn't even known i was out there i mean
eight years is a long time yeah because
it wasn't just that it was that coke
and the xanax just make you forget
everything like so by the end of the run
i was on
everything i was on probably about two
bundles of dope a day
five is a coke and about
five xanax every single day
it wasn't like i was working you know
what i'm saying i would wake up every
day like y'all got to go out and get
this money however means necessary robin
you know what i'm saying
do you feel like you were working to
keep your drug drug absolutely i had a
[ __ ] three four hundred dollar day
habit with no job nothing that's what
people always say if you have an
addiction i'm sure like you probably
applied to a sex addiction too like if
you have any sort of addiction like
you got to work on yourself the work
ethic to get high every day
right it's like yeah like imagine if
like most people who had that work ethic
to get high every day and still be semi
like
exactly they applied it to literally
anything else that's what i'm doing now
you never did you ever smoke crack no no
no never